make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking up with I guess picking
back up with Justice League rather from
Scott Snyder this was actually kind of
cool is this is a really cool a little
bit of a story and the reason why is
because again it kind of feeds into the
whole event of like the totality right
like that's really what's been going on
here is you have the totality basically
what seemed like a shard of the of the
the source wall or at least something
akin to it it just kind of careened
through space and time and then
eventually landed on earth and then
everything kind of popped off but around
the time that happened this is really
where the story kind of picks up is star
man arrived now in reality star man had
been experimented on and so on by Lex
Luthor right like we talked about that
in the previous videos that Lex Luthor
travel to the past in order to
understand the totality and experimented
on star man because star man himself
gained his powers after he was hit with
a piece of the totality and because
nobody really knew what it was when it
first arrived on earth nobody really
knew the basis behind it except for lil
Payton who had launched him seem to have
been gone and removed from the picture
the only way to really figure out what
was going on was to travel into the past
and try to try to you know figure out
how he worked now forced Lex Luthor
being Lex Luthor basically meant like
torture but the fact remains and that
with will Payton having arrived in the
modern day and basically like showing up
on the doorstep of the Justice League
Batman's been trying to understand what
in the world's going on with this and
like how will Payton ties into that and
what he's been doing is taking Jarra
like the small piece of Starro and
basically attaching it to will in order
to scan his mind and understand how it
all works now Batman's been hooking
himself up to it you know to a degree as
well in order to basically like read
basically like read will Payton's mind
kind of explore his mind through the the
stereo concept but of course again like
when it comes to any form of story it's
an astronomical amount of power and it's
so much they can overwhelm almost
anybody and even Batman almost died in
an attempt to make it happen now the
other half of this is again with the
kind of power that Starman possesses all
I would take is like one wrong turn and
like everything would cease to exist
right leg is one of those extreme
examples of the massive amount of power
that he contains within his mind and
again it's kind of cool but the funny
thing about this is that this Starman
concept is actually sort of a background
thing to all this where we would expect
answers almost right off the bat we
don't really get that instead what we do
is we shift over to thanagar prime now
of course dan Agartha Naggar prime is
home to like the thanagarians but really
like huh girl and Hawkman but for those
of you guys who are familiar with the
concept of Hawkgirl when like the Green
Lantern Martian Manhunter and Hawkgirl
arrived on this planet there
we met by share a hall after a bit of a
fight breaks out now those of you guys
who were familiar with that or kind of
like what like that doesn't make any
sense though and that was my first
thought my first thought was like what
like that bit no that's hot girl
so like hot girls meeting hot girl this
will all make sense here in a in a
little while but in the interim of
course because the fact that shayera is
very familiar with it she has been
around for a little bit again what kind
of tie all that anti all that up
together I hear at the end of the story
what is up happening here is she knows
the Justice leaguer friends and
basically speaks with the Justice League
directly now in terms of the reason why
the league is here is for a couple
different things of course the kind of
party like a big celebrations already
taking place anyway so that you know
like for these three folks are just kind
of mingling hanging out talking and so
on and so forth but then you also have
John Jones you sort of been in this
pursuit of like information in relation
to you what's left of the green Martians
with the nature of his people some of
that comes out of the solo series and
some of that are themes that are kind of
been on running throughout the book but
it's basically searching for a life the
keep which is basically a person who who
exists for the purpose of like
maintaining the records right so it's
kinda like the great record keeper of
the Martian race and Manhunters has
simply been looking for her in order to
understand like how all this works right
like everything with his people and so
on and so forth because members there's
a lot of things that are being changed
up when it comes to the character of
Martian Manhunter and so for people who
were new to DC rebirth it works out
because for old-school fans there's a
lot of familiarity here for people who
are new they're getting into it for the
first time and it all kind of ties them
together exceedingly well but as these
kind of conversations and these
different discussions go on what is up
happening is that is that hot girl
approaches shayera and basically says
like do you understand what's going on
with my wings can you read whatever this
is because remember with hawkgirl's
wings there's these intricate designs
and patterns that are showing up there
and it's kind of strange because she
doesn't really know what it is and
shayera seems to have this kind of
initial response like she does know but
this she responds my said we say well no
I I have no idea what that is I don't I
don't know I wish I could read it but
that's it and then of course when when
share attaches Hawkgirl suddenly there's
this kind of mental feedback that this
sort of punches into things and then
that's what she gets a hold of John
Jones and we end up finding out that
what's actually been going on here in
thanagar is that the Martian keep is is
present on this planet now shayera had
mentioned that in passing in sephora she
told john jones the keep was here at one
point but it's not anymore like like the
keepers is no longer here she passed on
she's dead and so it really seems a lot
you know seems duplicitous to a degree
the other part of this is that when
Hawkgirl begins to
figure out what's going on in the center
there are lies that are being told here
that well she basically tells John
Stuart and she tells John Jones that
leads into like the response of
basically like Savage Hawkman showing up
here now again for those of you guys who
are familiar with the hot girl and
Hawkman mythos you're probably just kind
of scratching your heads like what in
the world is going on why is Savage
Hawkman here because he should basically
be dead but is really kind of hitting
all the right marks because you've
literally got Savage Hawkman tearing
apart Hawkgirl and you would expect that
in this circumstance because the two of
them are essentially lovers who were
destined to like die and be reborn and
to always find each other that as soon
as Carter Hall sees sees a hot girl that
he would just kind of be like you're her
and like they would be together but
that's not what plays out instead it's
basically Shire Hall who has savage
Hawkman Cara Hall as her lover and is
saying like kill this girl and so it's
very intriguing because as we go through
this what we end up finding out is that
where this was this appeared to be
Hawkgirl the fact was that it actually
wasn't it was Martian Manhunter trickin
Shire and and Savage Hawkman into
basically like believing it was Hawkgirl
is actually super smart is if it's a
cool little thing to sort of throw in
here to kind of include in this bit of
the story but the reason why they're
going to the vaults is because the
vaults of Dan Agarn are basically like
legendary and all the places in all the
universe the vaults of thanagar are them
is the most secure place in all
existence if you have something that you
want to keep protected vana gar is a
place to have it the problem here is
that it takes forever to get anything
into that vault there are people who
wait years and you have to submit a
request and it could be decades before
you hear a response
it's that sought-after and it's that
well-protected what they end up doing is
kind of stowing away now this kind of
flies in the face of everything Snyder
says right like you cannot easily break
into a Naggar like it's designed to
basically like keep itself hidden but
the people who guard it only ever really
look for shapeshifters in the form of
like walking talking beings nobody ever
considers artifacts so that's kind of a
cool thing here is when you have one of
the one of the dominators who shows up
here with a giant shard of Krypton and
says hey look like this things got crazy
properties and we want to see if we can
use it to find a way to like duplicate
the powers of the Kryptonians or at
least to like duplicate the ability for
them to like draw power from sunlight
and so on of course they were they were
given approval by by Santa gark they
bring the artifact only for us to find
out it was basically Martian Manhunter
and the Green Lantern Hawkgirl
masquerading here before Martian
Manhunter himself he starts speaking
directly with the Martian keep
this is when answers start getting
revealed this is when things kind of
start spilling out all over the place
and basically telling us you know
exactly what's going on and what we
learn is that the multiverse as it
exists now in DC Comics is not the first
one is that the multiverse as it existed
before this one was created by Perpetua
and she basically had like all these
forces at her disposal and her power was
extreme eventually she was defeated and
she was locked behind the source wall
and then the guardians of the universe
being as cryptic as they are basically
eliminated almost all knowledge they
could have heard and that knowledge you
know what knowledge remained was
basically locked away in the thanagarian
vault as a result of this with the
Martian keep showing up here this really
serves two purposes or at least you know
with her existing here serves two
purposes one she has access to all that
information but to the other part of it
is now that informations being sought
and now that knowledge of Perpetual is
out there she's gonna make a return but
with this information basically being
thrown out there the other half of this
and what we learned with some of the
information is that it basically sets in
motion this basically this basically
kind of change up this retcon of the
origin of Martian Manhunter which will
actually cover in another video but at
the moment right now in terms of what's
going on here what Martian key basically
tells the Manhunter is not everything
here is what it seems in fact nothing
here is what it seems nothing here is
real that basically like this system as
it exists is because of like the
absorbacron literally an artifact that's
hooked up to me there's design to kind
of recreate Fanta guard but once I die
this will all fall away and when it does
chaos will ensue and that's exactly what
happens basically like the Martian keep
dies and then everything starts falling
apart clearly like the entire illusion
of of like thanagar starts to fade away
and that's what we begin to realize
what's going on here that Hawkman as he
existed was not real Savage Hawkman was
not real he was a construct shayera is
here and she's basically kept creating
like this giant illusion of like a
reinvigorated and fixed fan Agartha
that's why for those of you guys who
have been going through and been keeping
up with DC where the antig are was
basically in shambles and it seemed
perfectly fixed and back to the way it
was and even a little bit better before
it was almost completely and totally
collapsed the question was how did to
get that way this is how and so in the
middle of this great big huge conflict
that goes on and everything basically
going to pieces suddenly you end up
having the arrival of
Star Man and the Justice League from
Earth and this is kind of a cool little
thing in reality it's kind of Scott
Snyder making it work for the story but
also kind of making his like giving
himself a whole like giving himself a
way out
Stormin basically says is like Chiara as
she as she exists is basically not
supposed to be here technically she's
not supposed to exist and the reason why
is because she's one of the
personalities of Hawkgirl or one of the
beings of Hawkgirl was at some point in
the past remember when it comes to
Hawkman and Hawkgirl they're constantly
reborn and where those physical forms
will die their essences will basically
dissipate and then be reborn in another
form so technically speaking Shire Hall
should be dead and gone and then the
existing Hawkgirl should be the only
version of herself that's out there but
somewhere along the line perpetual fear
the fact that if Hawkgirl was fully
formed which is to say there was no
fraction of herself missing and floating
out there in the form of another being
that what would happen is a hot girl who
is fully in light integral would be a
threat to Perpetua and so what she did
is she split her in half and that
explains how shayera halls been here as
part of DC rebirth and so again like
storm and kind of fixes that he doesn't
really kill shayera so much as he says
look like the essence of you that
belongs to Hawkgirl I'm taking away and
I'm putting that directly into Hawk
Russell she's fully formed but you still
have your own soul Shai era Hall is now
a singular being now this can create
problems later on down the line this is
how he ran into problems with like Donna
Troy things like that this is how you
run into those kind of issues so I'm
curious how Scott Snyder will keep this
going forward without running into
continuity issues if he doesn't resolve
it somebody else later on we'll have to
try to find a way to figure it out or
it'll just be one of these things where
it goes on forever and this old version
of hawkgirl's floating around in the DC
universe and nobody knows what to do
with her and then she's just kind of
appearing every once in a while so again
it can kind of create problems this is
how those little this other things sort
of start now in the moment what you
basically have now is Shai era Hall this
older version of Hawkgirl who's out
there with her own essence and spirit
and experiences and so on but the part
of her that should have passed on and
become the new Hawkgirl has now been
returned to the new hot girls so she's
fully formed and fully together and so
following that the statement of star man
is there are a zillion things across
this universe that are all broken that
are all screwed up and they need to be
repaired and we'll start with a source
wall
the reality of this is that where you
look at Geoff Johns and Doomsday Clock
and Geoff John says okay so like
basically dr. Manhattan's screwed stuff
up he made some changes here and there
and now this is what this is what the
universe looks like now those changes
are made where Doomsday Clock seems like
it'll undo that this almost kind of
seems like scott Snyder's way of undoing
it on his own basically saying like
imagine if like Doomsday Clock never
happened but like we're trying to find a
way to bridge
gap between new 52 in DC rebirth this
kind of seems to be the answer for it
it's intriguing I'm sure it'll all
basically consolidate and it'll all kind
of make sense once once it's said and
done but it is intriguing to see how it
plays out and to see how all this kind
of kind of unfolds but with that being
said guys right go ahead bring us video
to an end if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]